the effect of kovat 19 on care homes in
Britain has been devastating these are
places where the elderly and frail
should hope to live out their lives in
comfort and safety and yet at least a
quarter of all kovat 19 deaths have
taken place in the sector which lies
outside Britain's National Health
Service and while there are signs the
worst of the crisis may have passed
experts warn against complacency we need
to see really clear evidence that PPE is
getting to care homes we need to see
comprehensive testing and that needs to
be on a rolling program and it needs to
test both staff and also the residents
of care homes we also need the NHS to
really upscale its support to care homes
at the start of this pandemic they
withdrew and now they need to be really
there shoulder to shoulder with the care
sector care home staff many poorly paid
and without medical training feel
particularly let down it's been many
decades now that Social Care hasn't been
receiving direct a respect and
recognition for the amazing work that we
do and I think this crisis particularly
shows how much Social Care is on the
frontline working hand-in-hand with the
NHS and that social care deserves parity
of esteem with the NHS as Britain
prepares to take the first tentative
steps back to work the government is
counting on a falling infection rate to
ensure the lockdown is lifted further
gradually sector by sector breathing new
life into the economy but there is a
weak link and that is social care in the
community at large the trends are
encouraging infection and fatality
numbers are falling steadily but Care
Homes are struggling to shake off what
critics described as early policy
failings by the government I don't know
what the motivation was behind the
decision but a decision was made it
seems to me with that community spread
was going to be allowed to to run fairly
unhindered and that Care Homes and the
most vulnerable were not going to be
protected Cove in 19 is one such net
sherrill event another is the annual flu
season in the autumn the great fear in
the sector is of a dual assault yet to
come against society's most vulnerable
people the government has promised
testing for all residents and staff by
early June and training in infection
control the wider concern is that new
outbreaks in Britain's care homes could
push the infection rate up and plunge
the country back into crisis jonah hull
al jazeera london